[موسيقى]
صباح الخير جميعًا
، أنا سعيد جدًا لوجودي هنا ، لقد تمت
برمجتك جميعًا طوال
حياتك طوال رحلتك وحياتك
كنت في عملية مشروطة
أوجدت
معتقداتك ، تحدث عن تأكيداتك طوال الوقت
سنوات تطورك إلى مرحلة البلوغ ،
لقد اكتسبت معتقدات من المجتمع من
الأصدقاء من التجارب للأسف
وللأسف المعتقدات بأننا
نكتسب العديد من المعتقدات التي
نكتسبها ضدنا وتمنعنا
من الوصول إلى أهدافنا من تحقيق
أحلامنا ، والخبر السار هو أنه يمكنك
دائمًا تغيير  المعتقدات واستبدال
المعتقدات السلبية بالمعتقدات
الإيجابية ،
يمكنك دائمًا إعادة إنشاء حياتك
وإنشاء مستقبل أفضل ،
دعني أولاً أغير الشريحة هذه حول
البرمجة ، هذه هي الطريقة التي تمت
برمجتنا بها ، لا أعرف من منكم يعرف
هذه الحقيقة نحن  كل شيء مبرمج
منذ الطفولة ، أرجوك Z ارفع
يدك جيدًا ممتعًا دعني أتحدث الآن
عن قصة شخصية هذه أنا
[أبل  ause]
عندما كنت في الثامنة من عمري
، توفي والدي والتقط هذه الصورة
قبل حوالي ثلاث سنوات من وفاته ،
كنا في الثامنة وأنا رقم سبعة في
العائلة ولم يتمكن أي منا من إدارة
أعمال والدي بعد
وفاته  في سن الثانية عشرة ، انتقلنا إلى
شقة أصغر ، لم يكن لدي غرفة ، كل
ما كان لدي في تلك الشقة الصغيرة
كان غرفة تخزين مساحتها مترًا
ونصف المتر في متر ونصف ، كانت
صغيرة جدًا ، كانت المكان الوحيد  في تلك
الشقة التي يمكنني تسميتها بشقتي ، كنت
أدرس هناك وأرسم أحلامي على
الجدران ، كان الوضع صعبًا
كانت الظروف محبطة ، لكن ما
جعلني قويًا ما جعلني
قويًا ومثابرًا وجادًا كانت
كلمات والدتي التي استخدمتها  لتأتي
إلي عندما أكون محبطًا ، اعتادت أن تقول إنني
أؤمن
بأنك ستحقق كل أحلامك ، وستحقق كل أهدافك
فقط العمل الجاد والصبر ، كانت الشائعات
صغيرة جدًا لكن أحلامي وأهدافي
كانت كبيرة جدًا أردت ذلك.  أكون طبيبا
أردت أن أكون ص  بسبب شغفي
بالصحافة والإعلام ، كنت أرغب في
التأثير على الناس ليكونوا إنسانيين وأن يكون
لهم تأثير إيجابي على الآخرين عندما
سافرت إلى Y ، حملت
معي معتقداتي ، حملت معي كلمات والدتي التي
أصبحت معتقداتي وحققت
أهدافي في الشريحة التالية من فضلك.
أسوأ ما في أمي التي أصبحت
معتقداتي شكلت حياتي وجعلتني ما
أنا عليه اليوم الآن لدي أحلام أكبر وأنا
أعلم أنني ممكن
الآن ربما يسأل الكثير منكم
ما هي تأكيداتنا ما هي تأكيدات الحديث الذاتي
هي الكلمات التي
تستخدمه مع نفسك أو مع الآخرين ،
وتعتقد أنك تؤمن جيدًا ،
ثم تتصرف بناءً على هذه
التأكيدات التي تتصرف بناءً عليها ، لذا
فهذه إما إيجابية أو سلبية عندما يكون
حديثك الذاتي إيجابيًا عندما تكون
تأكيداتك ومعتقداتك  هم إيجابيون
يربونك في الحياة ، لكن عندما
تتحدث مع نفسك بشكل سلبي فإنك تؤكد
نفسك بشكل سلبي ولديك
معتقدات سلبية يلعنك في
الحياة ، فلنرى ما الذي يعتقده لويس.
r الفيلسوفة
والمؤلفة الأكثر مبيعًا ما
قالته لأنها حياة إنها
امرأة تبلغ من العمر 90 عامًا. امرأة رائعة
قالت كل فكرة نفكر فيها
وكل كلمة نتحدثها تصنع
مستقبلنا والشهير واين داير أيضًا
قال الشريحة التالية ، من فضلك
قال في أي وقت تبدأ فيه جملة
مع أنا ، أنت تخلق ما أنت عليه
وما تريد أن تكونه ، قال أيضًا أن
ذراع I لديه القدرة على إنشاء
مستقبلك ، وللأسف ، يستخدم الكثير منا
التأكيدات السلبية وأنا  لديك
معتقدات سلبية ، على سبيل المثال ، يعتقد العديد من
الأشخاص بعد الفشل في مقابلة عمل
أنهم ليسوا جيدين بما يكفي ، فالكثير من
الناس يستيقظون في الصباح ويقولون يا
إلهي أنا قبيح ، يا إلهي ، أنفي كبير
أو ليس لدي  أنا أو أصدقائي
لأن هذه هي معتقداتهم ، هذه
هي المعتقدات التي اكتسبوها من
تجارب أسرة الطفولة واسمحوا لي أن
أخبركم بشيء اكتسبت
معتقدات سلبية أيضًا من طفولتي كانت أختي
تخبرني بحقيقتك وقالت
لك  لإنقاص وزني ، كان عمري ست
سنوات فقط وحملت هذا الاعتقاد
معي ، لكنني كنت محظوظًا بما يكفي لتغيير هذا
الاعتقاد إلى اعتقاد إيجابي وأنا في
وزني المثالي الآن كنت بدينة كما
قال أحد أفراد عائلتي ربي
فمك صغير كيف تأكل
وقد حملت ذلك يؤمن بي
وخمن ما غيرت هذا الاعتقاد إلى
إيجابي والآن أجني المال من خلال
التحدث وتقديم الأخبار من
فمي الصغير حتى تتمكن دائمًا من تغيير
معتقدك يمكنك دائمًا  غيّر
معتقداتك وستجد التغيير في
حياتك ، يمكنك دائمًا إعادة إنشاء
حياتك أو إنشاء مستقبلك
وأريد أن أخبرك أيضًا بمبدأ إنه
رائع ، استمع إلى هذا ، فأنت تدعوه إلى
حياتك مهما كان ما يلي أنا
أنت مدعو  حياتك مهما كان ما
يلي أنا إذا قلت إنني محظوظة ،
فأنت تدعو المزيد من النعم إلى حياتك
إذا قلت إنني بصحة جيدة ، فأنت تدعو إلى
حياة أكثر صحة ولكن إذا قلت إنني كبير في السن ،
فما الذي ستدعو إليه المزيد من
التجاعيد  وجهك ص  إذا قلت على
سبيل المثال في الواقع ، فإنك تدعو المزيد من السعرات الحرارية إلى
المزيد من الدهون لحياتك ، لذا كيف تتغير
أوه قبل ذلك ، يرجى الشريحة التالية ، من
فضلك
حسناً الآن ، أريدك أن ترى بعض
التأكيدات القوية والحديث الذاتي الذي
يستخدمه الأبطال لتحقيق
اعتاد محمد علي كلاي الأسطوري أن يقول إنني
أعظم من يجرؤ على القول إنني
أعظم
بطل ملاكمة في كل العصور.
كان هذا
تأكيده وإلهامي المفضل
والت ديزني الذي اعتاد أن يقول
إنه من الممتع القيام بالمستحيل
لتحقيق هذا النوع من المرح للسيد.
بارك الله في والت ديزني روحه الآن كيف
تغير معتقداتك السلبية إلى معتقدات
إيجابية بحثت عنها ووجدت
تمرينًا واحدًا استخدمته وقد نجح
معي في إحضار ورقة حسنًا ، يمكنك رسم
خط والورقة التي تحتفظ بها على الجانب الأيسر
إلى  التأكيدات السلبية المؤكدة
التي تستخدمها مع نفسك كأنني سمين
، أنا قبيح ، لست جيدًا بما يكفي ، لا
أستحق أهدافي ، ولا أعتقد أنني أستطيع
تحقيقها ، والجانب الصحيح
للتأكيدات الإيجابية التي هي
عكس ما تستخدمه مع
نفسك وبالمناسبة من خلال التكرار
عندما تكرر أشياء إيجابية
يأخذها العقل الباطن
وتصبح معتقداتك حول كيفية
عمل العقل الباطن على سبيل المثال ،
التأكيد السلبي المشترك
الذي يستخدمه الناس هو أنا '  لست جيدًا بما يكفي ،
لذا فأنت على حق ، فأنا لست جيدًا بما يكفي
إذا شعرت أنه عليك الجلوس هنا مع
نفسك وأن تكون صادقًا مع نفسك
وتجد ما يبقيك بعيدًا عن
أهدافك وأحلامك هنا أنا لست جيدًا  يكفي أن
تكتب على الجانب الأيمن  دي
للتأكيدات الإيجابية
أنا جيد بما فيه الكفاية على سبيل المثال ، إذا كنت
تخبر نفسك دائمًا أنني لا أستحق
أحلامي ، فأنا لا أستحق أن
أراك تكتب العكس الإيجابي ، فأنا
أستحق أحلامي ، فأنا أستحق أهدافي ، فأنا
كل ما تكتبه عني شابًا  حسنًا بعد
الكتابة أو كل معتقداتك السلبية
والمعتقدات الإيجابية المعاكسة ،
ما تفعله قص هذه الورقة إلى نصفين
حسنًا ،
قصها هكذا يمكنك أن ترى أنني أبدو
جميلًا هذا إذني
[ضحك]
حسنًا ، هذه هي معتقداتك السلبية
التي تمنعك من منع  أنت من
الوصول إلى أهدافك ، لذا فإن ما تفعله
هذا رمزي للغاية ، عليك أن تفعله
بمشاعر يجب أن
تشعر أنك تتخلص من معتقداتك السلبية
إلى الأبد ، حسنًا إذا كان لدى بعض الأشخاص
هنا ورقة وقلم على أي حال يمكنك الذهاب
المنزل والقيام بذلك ، يمكنك تكراره
بالمناسبة ، اعرف ما الذي نفعله الآن
نحن نتخلص من المعتقدات السلبية ،
أريدك أن تشعر أنك تتخلص
من المعتقدات السلبية إلى الأبد ، هذه هي
تأكيداتك الإيجابية التي حصلت عليها  قم
بإلغائها طوال الوقت في الصباح
عندما تقود سيارتك قبل أن
تنام وأريدك أن تكرر بعدي من فضلك
أنا جيد بما فيه الكفاية أنا أستحق أحلامي
أنا صغير انسى رقم أنا
جميل أشعر به أنت جميلة أنا '
أنا ناجح أنا بصحة جيدة ، أنا ممكن
والتأكيد الأخير هو أحد
التأكيدات المفضلة لدي ، أنا سعيد ولكن
أريدك أن تكررها بأغنية
ويرجى اختيار الأغاني الإيجابية دائمًا ،
موسيقى ، موسيقى ، موسيقى مصطفى ، نعم ، لذا
عليك تكرار هذا  تأكيد لأنني
سعيد بفصل الأغاني معًا ،
الجميع
[موسيقى]
أوه
الجميع
[موسيقى]
هذا ما
تريده مجددًا